okay I'm going to talk today about
converging lenses so what converging
lens is is a lens which converges light
what converge means is bring together
okay so every lens has something called
an axis this imaginary line that runs
through the middle
now along this axis somewhere we have a
focal point now different lenses have
different focal points that are
different distances from the lens the
stronger the converging of the lens the
closer the focal point is to the lens so
what we can see is light is going to
shine in from this way then it's going
to be refracted by the lens where all of
these rays of light converge is that
means come together is on our focal
point so I'm just going to draw a few
lines to show this okay right now I've
done it perfectly but you can see that
as these rays come in they're refracted
by the lens and they come together the
shape of this lens is called convex so
we can call this a convex lens or a
converging lens so what I'm going to do
next is I'm going to show you how to use
a converging lens to draw a ray diagram
of a particular image so let's imagine
here is my lens and let's just draw the
axis on that I'm also going to draw the
kind of to the midpoint of the lens
through the middle these kind of
imaginary lines and I'm also going to
imagine the focal point for this lens is
here okay so that's my focal point okay
now here is the image that I'm wanting
to draw a ray diagram of through the
lens so how do I do this what I do is I
take first of all the top part of the
image and I draw a line parallel to the
axis just like this if you were to do
this you'd use a ruler but
just doing it freehand for now I'm also
going to draw a line on this diagram to
show that's the way the lights coming
from okay now when it gets to the
midpoint of this lens it's refracted and
it's going to go through the focal point
okay as straight as you can
so again little arrow to show the
direction of the travel of the light now
what I do next is I take also from the
same point from the top of the image but
I'm going to draw a line straight
through the center point of the lens
because if this light I was straight
through that central point right there
it does not change direction so what I
can see here is both of these rays meet
just here this is where the top of my
image is going to be just here now
whenever the bottom of the image is on
the axis it means the bottom of the of
the image through the lens is also on
the axis so that's how I've done it so
key bits of information to remember are
converging lenses cause light to
converge to join in a particular focal
point also need to remember when we're
drawing an image so a ray diagram of an
image through a lens always stopped at
the top of the lens parallel line drawn
into the axis then a line going through
the focal point then the second line
goes from the top of the image right
through the central part of the lens and
that's where the top of the image is
thank you